one of the hallmarks of
pseudo-intellectualism
is to say things that are really simple
or overtly counterintuitive and to
pretend
that they're profound or that they give
some unique insight
something no one else is willing to say
maybe when in reality they're just wrong
now you might be saying david what are
you talking about i have an example for
you right here
um there is a guy who some might be
familiar with his name is tai
smith he's a conservative black father
who's being
popularized by right-wing media as a
conservative black father
who is willing to tell the truth about
race-related issues and the truth is he
sees it is
u.s isn't racist hasn't been racist and
now he even says
slavery wasn't racist in the united
states
let's just uh get right into it yeah
because they're
they're very invested in this whole idea
that
the nation was founded on the idea of
systemic racism that it's built into
every single institution in america even
in the military
right um folks are worried that this is
something that they need to address
within the military and we just did a
story about
how the navy is underprepared right now
but they're spending a heck of a lot of
time on this what do you think about
that
it's absolutely absurd because nobody
really wants to get the real history of
it
america was not founded on racism don't
get me wrong yeah there was slavery
going on but slavery itself was not
initially a racist thing it never
slavery itself
was not initially a racist thing and
right wingers watching fox
all of a sudden this guy appears and
they say whoa hold on a second
um it's fox so i trust it
and here's a black guy saying not only
was this
nation not racist in its in its
foundation but
even slavery wasn't racist and this
guy's black
so now i'm absolved of having to
actually deal with
any racial inequity or whatever i don't
have to feel guilty about anything as if
that's actually the point right
um this is crazy this is let's listen to
a little bit more
it was about race initially so to sit
there and take it like america was
founded on racism it's a complete lie
yeah there was slavery going on but
slavery was going on
in all the world it never was a race
thing so why are we making it a race
thing now
so there's a bunch of stuff there that
we can address all right
um the the one of the
things he says is sort of a red herring
right now it is
true that there were african slaves
in places other than the united states
he says slavery was going on all over
the world
it's true only about four to six percent
of
african slaves that were taken from
africa
came to the united states the other 94
to 96 percent
went to other places sometimes even
within africa they were enslaved
that doesn't change whether slavery in
the united states was racist i hope that
you realize that that's a complete and
total red herring
now sometimes what you will hear is
slavery in the u.s wasn't racist
because there were irish people also
enslaved
in colonial america early on
um that's also not true large numbers of
indentured servants
did come to the united states from
ireland and in fact went to numerous
british colonies
including uh those in north america they
they
chose to do it the conditions were
absolutely terrible
indentured servitude has elements of
slavery including that
you're you're bound to the whoever
you're working for for a period of time
but it's not actually slavery it's
terrible but indentured servitude
is not chattel slavery so that's another
argument that they will
sometimes make and then to even say that
there it wasn't racist in that i don't
even know what they mean do they mean
it just so happened that they were
bringing people from africa
all of whom were black um i don't know
how you argue that that's not
racist in its in its implementation and
if you you can even look at things
written at the time about slavery
one reason that you will find written
about why why is it african slaves that
are brought to the u.s
one reason is they were chosen for their
dark skin so they they could work out in
the sun
all day and i guess you know be less
susceptible to uh
to to to sun damage so how is that not
race based
and uh it's it's a very weak argument
but the question
that you really have to kind of ask is
what political point
is propped up by arguing that it wasn't
actually about race
who does it benefit politically it
benefits those
who want to do nothing right now about
inequalities that exist along racial
lines
to be able to say those inequalities are
not the result
of any historical racial oppression or
discrimination
as many people see it absolves them of
really having to figure out
or do anything about the circumstances
of racial inequality
in which the united states finds itself
today which are of course much improved
compared to what they were they are
not as bad as in many other countries as
i've said before
but they still exist and so that's the
political point that's the reason why
this is a narrative if you
if you can even gaslight people into
thinking
in the enslavement of african slaves
wasn't race-based or racist you can
essentially convince people of anything
and that's exactly what they're trying
to do here we'll have more about this on
our instagram
and i'd be curious to hear your thoughts
about it um
instagram on instagram we are david
pakman show all one word
and if you want to see my eggplant on
instagram that's at david.pacman i've
got
two eggplants now growing in the
backyard it's really a sight to see
follow me there we'll take a quick break
and be right back
our sponsor purevpn is having a huge
14th anniversary sale offering everybody
in my audience a subscription for under
three bucks
a month purevpn is a service
i trust because it has more servers than
any other vpn
on the market and it's the only vpn with
an always-on third-party audit to verify
that your internet activity is not being
logged
purevpn keeps me anonymous online keeps
me safe from hackers government
surveillance
any websites trying to track me and it
lets me
also access awesome streaming content
which wouldn't otherwise be available in
my country on platforms like netflix and
a whole bunch of others
i can stay logged into purevpn on up to
10 of my devices at the same time
and it's so easy to use you click two
buttons to set it up
you need no computer expertise at all
you can get purevpn at a huge discount
just
288 a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is right under this video
and you'll get
an additional 14 off when you use the
coupon code
hbd 14.